les brouettes sont prêtes elles
n'attendent plus qu'un preneur ce
weekend les jardiniers amateurs avaient
rendez-vous à la Ferme du Manet pour la
10è édition des prériales une fête des
fleurs solidaires en faveur des
personnes aveugles que ne manque jamais
Marie José j'ai acheté de la
consoude très bon engrais naturel je
suis plutôt écolo Gog c'est la première
fois je essayer de mettre une BA de
gogie au propriétés dans la plante à des
propriétés naturell antioxydantes et
puis mes géranium je remplis mes corb de
géranium le géranium c'est un peu
classique la nouveauté cette année c'est
le mur végétal où comment jardiner sans
mettre un pied dehors une idée de saison
avec le printemps qui peinene à
s'installer même les plantes restent au
chaud et si vous n'avez pas la main
verte vous pouvez toujours opter pour
ces plantes
dévitalisées par un procédé naturel la
la sève est remplacé par un mélange de
glucose et de glycérine et donc qui a
l'avantage de figer le végétal dans le
temps de lui permettre de garder sa
souplesse et son aspect naturel tout en
se passant complètement d'entretien ça
pas besoin de lumière ça pas besoin
d'arrosage et ça reste comme ça des
années et des années durant ce Leen
nordique coûte tout de même 190 € pas
sûr que les curieux investissent la
crise se fait sentir effectivement les
les gens
achètent avec plus de parimonie avec
plus de réflexion mais quand il s'agit
de se faire un petit peu plaisir et
d'avoir des fleurs dans son jardin c que
les gens sont prêts à dépenser un petit
peu c'est presque plus les côtés
décoration ou autre les investissements
lourds qui sont impactés entre billet
d'entrée location d'emplacement et
restauration 10000 € ont été récolté
soit 4000 de plus que l'année dernière
le Lions club pourra donc financer un 4è
chien guide d'aveugle Gena sera remise à
un habitant de satin d'ici
juillet